you heard it from Richard
Dawkins I find that I like to live in a
culturally Christian country although I
do not believe a single word of the
Christian faith you heard it from Ayan
her Al and that idea that there is
something above us a higher power I
think
that that is rooted in Christianity it's
rooted in the judeo-christian traditions
and in many ways it is superior to the
nihilistic init type
um atheistic theology you even heard it
from Joe Rogan we need we need
Jesus I think for real like if he came
back now it' be great like Jesus if
you're thinking about coming back right
now now's a good time pretty soon yeah
everyone's starting to realize that the
new atheists with all their assurances
that if we just get rid of religion
people will become more rational had
absolutely no clue what they were
talking about the new atheists had as
much Blind Faith in the coming
scientific Utopia as the Jihadi has in
his 72 virgins and that Blind Faith of
the new atheists is destroying Western
Civilization here's a new article from
the Atlantic to add to our ever
expanding collection of Lamentations
from all the atheist aists and agnostics
who are in the process of being
repeatedly throat punched by
reality the true cost of the churchgoing
bust and the description many Americans
seem to have found no alternative method
to build a sense of community by Derek
Thompson as an agnostic I have spent
most of my life thinking about the
decline of faith in America in mostly
positive terms organized religion seem
to me beset by Scandal and entangled in
noxious politics so I thought what is
there really to mourn only in the past
few years have I come around to a
different view maybe religion for all of
its faults Works a bit like a retaining
wall to hold back the destabilizing
pressure of American hyper individualism
which threatens to swell and spill over
in its
absence Richard Dawkins saw it long long
before you saw it Derek you call it a
retaining wall he called it a bull workk
Dawkins was referring to something a
certain religion was protecting you from
when he said way back in 2010 I have
mixed feelings about the decline of
Christianity in so far as Christianity
might be a Bull workk against something
worse or as he warned in a 2018 tweet
before we Rejoice at the death throws of
the relatively benign Christian religion
religion let's not forget hir Bell's
menacing rhyme always keep a hold of
nurse for fear of finding something
worse more than one quarter of Americans
now identify as atheists agnostics or
religiously unaffiliated according to a
new survey of 5600 us adults by the
public religion Research Institute this
is the highest level of non- religiosity
in the poll's history 2/3 of non
Believers were brought up in at least
nominally religious households like me I
grew up in a reformed Jewish Home that I
would describe as haphazardly religious
in kindergarten my parents encouraged my
sister and me to enthusiastically
celebrate Hanukkah and just as fervently
to believe in Santa Claus but more
Americans today have converted out of
religion than have converted to all
forms of Christianity Judaism and Islam
combined no faith evangelism has been as
successful in this Century as religious
skepticism and as this religious
skepticism has spread so have science
and logic and reason and ah who am I
kidding we can't even figure out what a
girl is
anymore secularization is old news the
Scientific Revolution that pitted the
church against stargazers like Galileo
comes from the 1600s and N famously
declared God is dead in the
1880s I think Derek needs a refresher on
the history of Science and
philosophy but even as secularism surged
throughout the developed world in the
20th century America's religiosity
remained exceptional seven in 10
Americans told Gallup that they belonged
to a church in
1937 and even by the 1980s roughly 70%
said they still belonged to a church
synagogue or mosque suddenly in the the
1990s the ranks of non-believers surged
an estimated 40 million people one in8
Americans stopped going to church in the
past 25 years making it the largest
concentrated change in church attendance
in American history according to the
religion writer Jake meter in 2021
membership and houses of worship fell
below a majority for the first time on
record anyone else noticed that as
membership and houses of worship plummet
people losing their minds
skyrocketed maybe it's just a
coincidence the sudden decline of
religion likely relates to changes in
both politics and family life in the
1970s and 80s the religious right became
a formidable fundraising machine for the
Republican party as the GOP Consolidated
its Advantage among conservative
Christians religion seemed less
appealing to Liberal young people
especially if they or their parents all
already had a tenuous relationship with
the church in the late 1980s only one in
10 liberals said they didn't belong to
any religion 30 years later that figure
was about 4 in 10 meanwhile the decline
of marriage especially among low income
Americans accompanied their move away
from the
church so there's some sort of
correlation between moving away from the
church and a decline in marriage but
that'll be good for society too right
who needs that archaic I Now pronounce
you husband and wife
nonsense that relationship with
organized religion provided many things
at once not only a connection to the
Divine but also a historical Narrative
of identity a set of rituals to organize
the week and year and a community of
families prri found that the most
important feature of religion for the
dwindling number of Americans who still
attend Services a few times a year
included experiencing religion in a
community and instilling values in their
children so as people abandon religion
they're losing a connection to the
Divine a historical Narrative of
identity rituals to organize the week
and year a community of families
experiencing religion in a community and
a system for instilling values in their
children but what could go
wrong how about everything everything
can go wrong when I read the prri survey
this emphasis on community is what
caught my eye as I recently reported the
United States is in the midst of a
historically unprecedented decline in
face-to-face socializing the social
collapse is steepest for some of the
groups with the largest declines in
religiosity for example young people who
are fleeing religion faster than older
Americans have also seen the large lest
decline in socializing boys and girls
ages 15 to 19 have reduced their
Hangouts by more than 3 hours a week
according to the American time use
survey there is no statistical record of
any period in US history where young
people were less likely to attend
religious services and also no period
when young people have spent more time
on their own but that's working out
really well for young people just check
Tik Tok to see how things are going be
sure to bring some soap because you're
going to want to wash your eyeballs out
after a few
minutes a similar story holds for
workingclass Americans in 2019 a team of
researchers published a survey based on
long interviews conducted from 2000 to
2013 with older lowincome men without a
college degree in workingclass
neighborhoods around the country they
found that since the 1970s Church
attendance among white men without a
college degree had fallen even more more
than among white college graduates for
many of these men the loss of religion
went hand inand with the retreat from
Marriage as marriage declined the
authors wrote men's church attendance
might have fallen in tandem today low
income and unmarried men have more alone
time than almost any other group
according to Time use data that's one
way to stick it to the
patriarchy did the decline of religion
cut some people off from from a crucial
gateway to Civic engagement or is
religion just one part of a broader
Retreat from associations and
memberships in America it's hard to know
what the causal story is here Eric
kleinenberg a sociologist at NYU told me
but what's undeniable is that
non-religious Americans are also less
civically engaged this year the Pew
Research Center reported that
religiously unaffiliated Americans are
less likely to volunteer
less likely to feel satisfied with their
community and social life and more
likely to say they feel lonely clearly
more Americans are spending Sunday
mornings on their couches and it's
affected the quality of our Collective
life he said less civically engaged less
likely to volunteer less likely to feel
satisfied with their community and
social life more likely to say they feel
lonely small price to pay for getting
rid of Jesus though am I right right
kleinenberg doesn't blame individual
Americans for these changes he sees our
Civic Retreat as a story about place in
his book palaces for the people
kleinenberg reported that Americans
today have fewer shared spaces where
connections are formed churches
libraries Parks School gyms and union
halls people today say they just have
fewer places to go for Collective life
he said places that used to Anchor
community life like libraries and school
gyms and union halls have become less
accessible or shuttered
altogether many people having lost the
scaffolding of organized religion seem
to have found no alternative method to
build a sense of
community don't miss that last part
people are losing the scaffolding of
organized religion but they haven't
found an alternative method for building
a sense of community as we'll see in in
the coming months and years they haven't
found an alternative for lots of things
for more than two decades the new
atheists have been ripping up the
foundations of society but they've never
come up with anything that can replace
those
foundations turns out patting yourself
on the back and bragging about how smart
you are and spending every waking moment
posting Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy
Sky daddy Sky Daddy on Twitter just
isn't enough to keep Society from
collapsing now for a thought experiment
Imagine by analogy a parallel universe
where Americans suddenly gave up on
sitdown restaurants in surveys they
named many reasonable motivations for
their abstinence the expense the overuse
of salt and sugar and butter the
temptation to drink alcohol as
restaurants disappeared by the hundreds
some mourned their closure While others
said it simply didn't matter after all
there were still plenty of ways for
people to feed themselves Over time
however Americans as a group never found
another social activity to replace their
dining out time they saw less of one
another with each passing decade
sociologists noted that the demise of
restaurants had correlated with a rise
in aloneness just as the CDC noticed an
increase in anxiety and
depression I've come to believe that
something like this story is happening
except with organized religion playing
the role of restaurants on an individual
basis people can give any number of
valid sounding reasons for not
frequenting a house of worship but a
behavioral shift that is fully
understandable on the individual level
has coincided with and even partly
exacerbated a great rewiring of our
social
relations
aha you are an individual but you're
also part of a society if one person
acts differently Society doesn't change
but if millions of people start acting
differently Society gets
rewired so how do you like the direction
society's heading and America didn't
simply lose its religion without finding
a communal replacement just as America's
churches were depopulated Americans
developed a new relationship with a
technology that in many ways is the
Diabolical opposite of a religious
ritual the
smartphone as the social psychologist
Jonathan hey writes in his new book The
anxious generation to stare into a piece
of glass in our hands is to be removed
from our bodies to float placeless in a
Content Cosmos to skim our attention
from one piece of ephemera to the next
The Internet Is Timeless in the best and
worst of ways and everything store with
no opening or closing times in the
virtual world there is no daily weekly
or annual calendar that structures when
people can and cannot do things height
writes in other words Digital Life is
disembodied asynchronous shallow and
solitary when people lose their external
structure they begin to lose their
internal structure their mental
structure
and they go
insane religious rituals are the
opposite in almost every respect they
put us in our body height writes many of
them requiring some kind of movement
that marks the activity as devotional
Christians kneel Muslims prostrate and
Jews doav religious ritual also fixes Us
in time forcing us to set aside an hour
or day for prayer reflection or
separation from daily habit it's no
surpr that people describe a scheduled
break from their digital devices as a
Sabbath finally religious ritual often
requires that we make contact with the
sacred in the presence of other people
whether in a church mosque synagogue or
over a dinner table prayer in other
words the religious ritual is typically
embodied synchronous deep and Collective
you can think of religious rituals as a
trellis for you to grow on on you're a
grape vine you can exist as a grape vine
on the ground but you're not going to be
very fruitful if you want to be fruitful
you need a structure to grow on I'm not
advocating that every atheist and
agnostic in America immediately choose a
world religion and commit themselves to
weekly church or synagogue or mosque
attendance but I wonder if in forgoing
organized religion an isolated country
has discarded an old and proven source
of ritual at a time when we most need it
making friends as an adult can be hard
it's especially hard without a scheduled
weekly reunion of congregants finding
meaning in the world is hard too it's
especially difficult if the oldest
systems of meaning making hold less and
less appeal it took decades for
Americans to lose religion it might take
decades to understand the entirety of
what we
lost ever notice that everyone who
promises to guide us to some Utopia
inevitably ends up leading us closer to
a
dystopia communism socialism the new
atheism
wokeism people come up with theories
that make sense in their heads these
deep thinkers solve all the world's
problems in their heads with their
theories
but they should have kept those theories
in their heads because their theories
don't work in the real
world as the Scottish philosopher Thomas
Reed put it a traveler who has good
judgment may mistake his way and be led
unawares onto a wrong route and for as
long as the wrong road in front of him
is open and passable he may go on
without suspicion and be followed by
others
but when the road ends at a coal pit he
doesn't need much judgment to know that
he has gone wrong and perhaps to find
out what has led him
astray new
atheists you thought you were guiding
Society on the right path but now we
find ourselves falling deeper and deeper
into a coal pit Will there come a time
when you champions of evidence actually
pay attention to the mountains of
evidence all around you and conclude
that you are way out of your depth and
that your theories about how to improve
the world are far more dangerous to the
world than the boogeyman of religion
that frightens you
[Music]
so
yeah